previously on TV said it's a simple
routine involving lasers anyways the key
to this plan is the giant laser it was
invented by the noted Cambridge
physicist dr. Parsons therefore we shall
call it the Alan Parsons Project
[Music]
so the TARDIS is smart enough to know
where and time and space to go and
advance enough to blend into its
environment but it can't do anything
about the landing sounds that are
apparently loud enough to hear over loud
music and someone using a hammer and
chisel and a garage several blocks away
before it's even materialized this scene
does not contain a Christopher Eccleston
Merry Christmas what is up with roses
tardy TARDIS exit she takes some time
after that crash landing to freshen up
even though she knew the new and
improved doctor would need her help what
do you mean that's the doctor doctor
home role who mortals know I still say
we should take him to a hospital
come on they'd lock him up they dissect
him one bottle of his blood could change
the future of the human race how is it
even remotely possible this scenario has
never happened before as much as the
doctors been involved with in this world
at least once someone would have dropped
him off at a hospital he's got two
hearts oh don't be stupid really Jackie
you're drawing the line at extra organs
you see a police box shaped spacecraft
crash-land into London with a
transforming creature who has an
entirely new body and the extra ticker
is the thing giving you pause different
face or is he a different person I
should I know not gonna lie regeneration
may be one of the smartest signs my
concepts for television ever invented we
could argue that this single idea is
what has allowed this show to stay
relevant since 1963 with the ability to
breathe fresh life into it wherever it's
needed it's a game changer well worth a
few cents off festival he starts to
different to the door nice it back of
oranges is it's a bag of oranges one of
those clever and British rhyming slang
things for some sort of sexual encounter
let's see bag of oranges oranges again
good more than that stop code will free
over always got a one-up don't we Rose
Rose British workmanship sailing up
there among the stars the unmanned probe
Guinevere one is about to make its final
descent
whoa that live press conference turned
into an expositional broadcast about
landing on Mars faster than a Whovian
will berate you for not fully spelling
out doctor well that certainly looked
what's the opposite of realistic again
and yes I can hear all the who's in
Whoville tonight telling me the cheap
effects are callback to the old series
but this [ __ ] looks like rankin/bass put
it together for their lost 60s Christmas
special Santa Claus is coming to Mars
and in 2005 that's just not good enough
there's another one because that's who I
can listen to all day tardes this is
that geez Mickey it's not like she's
droning on about serving wankers at the
local chip shop she's traveling through
time how are you not interested she's
dying okay just let me Christmas can you
do that yeah I haven't forbid you'd be
concerned about your dying friend no
reason to let silly things like that get
in the way of a Christmas Eve hookup if
so this seems like an incredibly
inefficient way to come after you did
they just wait here as this Christmas
brass band all evening until you just
happen to wander in front of them and
why couldn't they have started the
trombone aside when Rose and Mickey were
unaware and shopping instead of
finishing their song first sleep vaping
these must be the most inept and
particular aliens ever if you got into
this house to set the tree up why not
just take the doctor that the spinning
tree of death just went through a wall
like it was made of jelly babies and
somehow this gateway to Narnia is
holding it at bay help me do you sex
Annika so they eliminate the defense
but again if doctor napping the napping
doctor is the goal here there are
approximately 471 boatloads of better
ways to do that than a remote control
coniferous this goes on for some time
we're going to end that sentence to
start with right so if you needed
something that bad why do you never
mention it again sorry and whatever
we're arguing it takes a bite out of it
like some sort of [ __ ] you know or -
me character has very important
information but can't get it out before
collapsing cliche britain's mission to
mars have reestablished contact with the
Guinevere one space probe my favorite
thing about news position is how the
news cast seemed to conveniently take
place right when there is a lull in the
action and just when we need the
information the most we're back on
schedule schedule so what the doctor
means is we had them now we get that and
thankfully Mickey knew about the web
site explanation video for whatever
random bit of info you were given by a
time-traveling doctor calm the human
race has been shown absolute proof that
alien life exists happy though unit is
putting on a pretty convincing cover
story because that totally looks exactly
like someone wearing a lousy alien mask
I know the broadcast is supposed to be
from
but with the news be so definitive about
it when someone at Mission Control could
just be taking the piss said it was a
hoax some sort of mask or prosthetics
students hijacking the signal that sort
of thing the sort of thing where your
security is so laxed that some random
college kids could hack into a
multi-million dollar space probe that
seems like it would be a lot more
embarrassing and destructive than just
admitting it was a real alien take a
look over access to the military so
we're just gonna yada yada that whole
Mickey has access to the military
mainframe part of this whole thing cool
TARDIS translates alien languages inside
my head all the time wherever I am
doctor who manages to somehow make Star
Trek's universal translator seem legit
must be the doctor he's breaking you do
eventually have the doctor in this
Doctor Who episode right I feel like
we're spending most of our time with him
out of commission and his doctor crew
just flailing around like they haven't a
doctor clue what the doctor did this
doctor flu is making me doctor blue you
can tell the President and please use
these exact words he's not my boss and
he's certainly not turning this into a
wall holy hell this take place in 2018
speaking strictly off the record
government sources are calling this our
longest night well then since you kind
of just put that on the record good luck
getting info from these sources in the
future I don't suppose we've had a
code-nine
no sign of the doctor if you're going to
ask the question directly why even
mention the code isn't that supposed to
be part of the secret
we have codes for a reason Harriet
Bayrou died not you will die they will
die who's they apparently even the
sicker acts are proficient at the
pronoun gate yes and I'm guessing that
love will build through many years and
develop into something special and then
the next thing you know it's a bag of
oranges and they live happily ever after
right right I realize the cigarettes are
controlling a portion of the population
to step towards high ledges and all but
they are still physical human beings
right because if I had kids or spouse
zombie walking toward their death I
think I might do a little more to stop
them and just stand behind them and beg
one-third of the world's population
that's two billion people reading some
Jama discount Thanos is that really the
shape of their spaceship someone needs
to teach the sick of ants or Skrillex or
whatever the hell these aliens are
called about aerodynamics beg of you now
show that compassion
to be fair that could be the sicker acts
version of a hug it's bigger on the
inside so they accidentally themselves
into the alien ship and now they have
accidentally themselves into something
that will heal the doctor well
convenience has never cease did you miss
me audience applause break but also
David Tennant man a passion humor
intelligence charisma and gravitas he
injects into this character in the next
15 minutes defines everything about why
this show works all the respect for my
doctor did not change
oddly enough rude and not ginger was the
name of my high school Christian ska
trance band so if I see a great big
threatening button which should never
ever ever be pressed I just want to do
this I get that the doctor knew that was
the device controlling all da positives
but he didn't know where they were being
controlled and you're telling me not a
single person walk forward instead of
backwards once they were given the free
will back you accept my challenge but if
the TARDIS is still translating
everything into the language of who
hears it why would this apparently
profane and salt be any different does
the TARDIS have a BBC standards and
practices chip thanks comic kilgrave
would be excellent at TV since you've
come on yes but you do have blood right
I mean I know you're about to Deadpool
yourself a new skipper gripper and all
but unless those two hearts of yours or
pumping air shouldn't at least a little
bit of blood seep out you mean like
blood control just saying maybe don't
throw stones at glass tortoises sticker
axion warrior so earlier when you said
that she couldn't interfere by helping
you or violated the challenge apparently
tossing you a new weapon doesn't count
our second chances okay badassery of
this no second chances moment assigned
exactly why is there a button by the
door that opens up some sort of trapdoor
Peninsula at the edge of the ship and
how was meat mouth even still on it when
he had already run like three or four
steps it's a message from Torchwood they
say they're ready for what to be a
successful spin-off it's debatable who
Doctor Who
many of these trees will my friends
[Music]
don't you just hate it when you're
undergoing regeneration and an alien
species tries to use your temporary
moment of weakness to mount an attack on
earth if you don't have a sonic
screwdriver you should try using nord
VPN to keep the baddies at back nor word
VPN that's Virtual Private Network uses
their military-grade encryption services
to keep your information safe from
hackers malware and even the cigarettes
it's not when you fancy someone I don't
even know you exist and for a limited
time you can get 75% off a three-year
plan at Nord VPN comm / T visas plus if
you use the code DB sims at checkout you
can get an extra month of service for
free use that extra cash to buy yourself
something fancy three words for you
treat yo self Nord VPN also offers 24/7
customer support and is totally
risk-free with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so if you're like me and spend
too much time in the weirdest corners of
the Internet
I'm not judging you or have trouble
keeping your head straight until that
first cup of tea and you really need to
check out Nord VPN go to Noor VPN comm
slash TV sins and use code TV sins to
keep your browsing secure for just $2.99
a month and an extra month for free help
the doctor to defeat the sicker acts and
protect yourself online today
party on did anything else he's got 200
P that's not rock it's a specification
the president's insisting that he take
control of the situation
sorry dear I was miles away I want to
know absolutely everything that's
happened up to now well let's see first
the earth cool and then the dinosaurs
came
happy the gold dragons your shoes got a
joke for the planet for the planet first
butter for freedom
[Music]
now I'm Nikki